Okay.
There is sort of an impeachment hearing against
Donald Trump that has started and I really
thought long and hard about how to approach
this story.
Um, and the first sort of question we have
to ask is, is this really an impeachment hearing
that has started when the House Judiciary
Committee?
And uh, my sense is that it's not a, this
is being called a quote impeachment hearing,
but I don't actually think that that is the
right name for it.
This is a hearing which depending on what
happens in some abstract sense could lead
to an actual impeachment inquiry.
And this is already, if you're saying, David,
that sounds muddled.
This is why I think that this is extraordinarily
problematic.
Problematic.
I try to tell you things as I see them truly
without over or understating the importance
of something.
And the way that this has gone down so far
is seeming to me like a self destructive waste
of time.
And I'll explain why.
So yesterday the House Judiciary Committee
had a hearing.
They started interviewing, uh, Donald Trump's
former campaign manager, Corey Lewandowski.
Corey Lewandowski gave Democrats nothing.
And in fact, he generated some really good
soundbites that right wing media and Donald
Trump are absolutely gushing about.
He stonewalled.
He brought a letter with him from the White
House, a lawyer, pat chip Alini saying that
executive privilege has been invoked.
Now there is an obvious question about, wait
a second.
Corey Lewandowski was the campaign manager,
meaning Donald Trump was not president at
the time that he was instructing Corey Lewandowski
to do things.
Could executive privilege really even be asserted
given that Trump wasn't president at the time?
It's a question that would have to be fought
out legally and we don't have an answer to
that.
In the immediate, um, uh, he refused to answer
questions about conversations with Donald
Trump, uh, like a very well behaved tool of
Donald Trump and Trump praising him for it.
And in the end, this to me was a pointless
waste of time gong show this was going to
be the way it went down from day one.
Lewandowski, even before the executive privilege
letter was written and presented, said that
he was looking forward to defending Donald
Trump in these hearings.
They were never going to get anything from
Lewandowski.
So then the question became in not getting
anything from Lewandowski can democrats make
him.
And by Extension Donald Trump look bad enough,
look guilty enough to um, further the arguments
of, uh, impeachment and a real bonafide impeachment
inquiry.
And I've said before, the whole point of an
impeachment inquiry if one were to be done,
would not really be to remove Donald Trump
via impeachment because it's not going to
happen.
A Republican Senate is not going to convict
Donald Trump on the basis of what's happened
so far, certainly not before the November
of 2020 election.
The whole point in my view of an impeachment
inquiry would be to publicize the content
of the Mueller report.
What's in the Mueller report is devastating
to Trump.
Most of the public has not read the Mueller
report.
So you do the impeachment inquiry to get the
content of the Mueller report out there front
and center.
It distracts from Trump's campaigning.
It may send Trump into a frenzy on Twitter
where he may end up further self incriminating.
The only interesting thing that came out of
this hearing that could be advantageous to
democrats is that Corey Lewandowski refused
to say whether Donald Trump preemptively offered
him a pardon.
It's very interesting.
Ultimately, I don't think that's going to
go anywhere.
We already know colloquially informally that
Donald Trump has in place implicitly dangled
pardons in front of people and it has had
absolutely no consequences.
So I think that this ultimately is a mistake.
I believe that if you are really going to
do a proper impeachment inquiry, you do it.
You very clearly label it as such and it is
an impeachment investigation.
This is a sort of, we've got some Democrats
saying they believe Trump is impeachable,
but this is just a hearing to talk to people,
which depending on what they say could become
a full blown impeachment inquiry or attempt
to impeach.
I've said before, I'm fine with an impeachment
inquiry.
If we're going to do it, I'm fine with saying
we're not going to do the impeachment inquiry.
Let's just focus on removing Donald Trump
electorally in November of 2020 I'm fine with
it either way, but this off-handed hearing
of something that could sort of de facto be
an investigation into whether there should
be impeachment vote the guy out in 2020 and
remove him.
And if you look at the media coverage over
the last 24 hours of this right wing media
is doing what we know they were going to do.
They are going to say, this is a partisan
witch hunt.
Corey Lewandowski went in there, he gave them
nothing.
Trump's happening it.
Trump's happy with it.
It unites the right around.
We're not going to let Democrats pull this
off.
And then on the left you hear Democrats saying
Lewandowski stonewalling.
He's not answering questions, et Cetera, but
this is what they've been doing all along.
There is no additional benefit to this.
So it, it's, I'm calling this a halfhearted
pseudo impeachment, maybe hearing where witnesses
will say nothing.
I don't know what type of PR they expect to
get.
That's beneficial to the cause of removing
Donald Trump, but it is seeming to me very
miscalculated.
Now I'm willing to have my mind changed.
If you saw this and you thought, yeah, this
is good, this is going to help us achieve
something and let me know what that is and
how it's going to help achieve it.
As you know, I, I just call things what they
are and this is the way this looks to me.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman and the show is
on Twitter at David Pakman show and make sure
you're also following me on twitch at twitch.tv/david
Pakman for live streams happening weekly